und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend am tag nach thüringen wissen die
meisten beteiligten vor allem was sie
nicht wollen
das ist zwar verständlich wird bei der
regierungsbildung in erfurt aber nicht
helfen bei der cdu löst dieses dilemma
einen grundsatzstreit aus der bis hinauf
in die bundesspitze in berlin reicht
schon dass der thüringer hat
cdu-parteichef mike mohring überhaupt
mit dem linken ministerpräsidenten
ramelow reden wollen geht einigen zu
weit
während er von verantwortung für das
land spricht fordern die anderen haltung
und klare kante
das erinnert doch irgendwie an die spd
mit ihren flügelkämpfen und ihrem dauer
leiden zwischen profil und pragmatismus
und darf gespannt sein wie das
weitergeht entführungen und bei der cdu
die junge union mit deren vorsitzenden
ich vor der sendung ein interview
geführt habe ist der hand aufgebracht
dass sie sogar die führungsfrage stellt
mathis feldhoff berichtet es war ein
kurzer flirt des thüringer cdu
spitzenkandidaten mit dem unmöglichen
mike mohring hatte gespräche mit
wahlgewinner bodo ramelow nur erwähnt
schon hatte der rest seiner partei
schaum vor dem mund dabei hatte mohring
die worte koalition mit der linken nicht
mal ausgesprochen
trotzdem der verantwortung für dieses
land und ich glaube nicht dass die
verantwortung heißt dass wir zulassen
können dass die abgewählte ramelow
regierung einfach im amt sitzen bleibt
und geschäftsführend weiter macht
sondern das braucht stabile verhältnisse
und wir werden dafür auch unser wort
machen unser beitrag leisten wie hältst
du es mit den rändern die cdu krallt
sich geradezu an ihre prinzipien
wir werden überflüssig wenn wir egal mit
links oder mit der linkspartei oder mit
der afg koalieren würden dann braucht es
uns nicht mehr dem rosa luxemburg haus
ist das heute ziemlich egal
hier freut man sich bodo ramelow hat
zwar die wahl gewonnen aber was daraus
wird entscheidet die partei das muss
auch der wahlgewinner erkennen diese
gespräche über die frage wie könnte ein
politisches modell in thüringen aussehen
kann
nur mit meiner partei beredet werden und
die einladung dazu ergeht von meiner
partei aber ist ramelow ein
konservativer linker einer mit dem auch
die cdu könnte wenn die partei nicht
wäre eine debatte die der vorsitzenden
der linken gar nicht gefällt
alle versuche hier irgendwie einen keil
zwischen die linke und boden zu treiben
die werden uns so was von abfällen weil
das ist einfach ein super team und das
voller wertschätzung zwischen dem
imperium der linken und andersrum
so wird mike mohring zwar ein gespräch
mit bodo ramelow führen mehr wohl aber
nicht stattdessen widmet sich die cdu
bei ihrer fehleranalyse ihren
derzeitigen lieblingsprojekt der
demontage der vorsitzenden als der junge
vorsitzende intern die führungsfrage
stellt kalter kaka zurück wer immer
meint die frage müsse jetzt in diesem
herbst entschieden werden
der hat auf dem bundesparteitag dazu die
gelegenheit doch die blumen und das
küsschen zu beginn verdecken nur die
harte kritik die ak sich heute anhören
musste kritik die oft nicht mal ihren
namen endlos wir sind jetzt monatelang
ja zum teil den grünen hinterher
gelaufen haben nur und ausschließlich
über das thema klima gesprochen
es gibt aber noch 819 andere
herausforderungen in deutschland und das
spüren die menschen nur wenn man die
sachen wirklich klar beim namen benennt
und bereit ist auch konsequenzen zu
ziehen kann es hier einen aufwärtsschub
geben und dann noch einen satz der kramp
karrenbauer nur oberflächlich in schutz
zu nehmen scheint einsatz der
entschuldigend beginnt aber ziemlich
hart endet annegret kramp karrenbauer
ist nicht die einzige die hier im
mittelpunkt der kritik zu stehen hat
sondern es gibt auch andere und das
gesamte erscheinungsbild der deutschen
bundesregierung ist einfach
grottenschlecht kramp karrenbauers blick
wirkt heute verbissen wie auf abwehr als
würde sie ahnen dass die härteste zeit
gerade erst beginnt
und der bundesvorsitzende der jungen
union tillmann kuban ist uns
zugeschaltet gelernter kuban
guten abend slomka werden sie jetzt so
der kevin kühnert der cdu in kiel hat
seinen eigenen stil ich habe meinen auch
und ich bin sehr stolz darauf dass wir
als junge union eigenständig sind auch
manchmal die cdu etwas treiben
aber wir wollen etwas gemeinsam
erreichen nämlich dass wir auch in
zukunft das kanzleramt mit jemandem aus
der cdu und csu aus der union gemeinsam
besetzen mit jemandem das klingt jetzt
nicht unbedingt nach das ist auf jeden
fall der partei vorsitzende annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das haben sie auch
heute im vorstand in frage gestellt ich
habe deutlich gemacht dass wir ein
verfahren brauchen dass wir gemeinsam
festlegen wollen wie wir zu einer
kanzlerkandidatur kommen wir haben
momentan eine offene führungsfrage
innerhalb der union
und die muss gelöst werden weil sie die
menschen verunsichert und diejenigen
wollen keine endlosen debatten sondern
sie wollen eine klare führung die muss
die union liefern dann hat frau kramp
karrenbauer sie quasi dazu eingeladen zu
sagen gut also wir haben jetzt in einem
monat ein bundesparteitag dann mal los
warnt farbe bekennen werden wir das tun
ich persönlich halte nichts von
schnellschüssen sondern wir haben uns
auf dem deutschlandtag der jungen union
dafür ausgesprochen dass die basis
eingebunden werden soll
mit einer urwahl und deswegen sollten
wir nach diesem verfahren für das wir
auch streiten dann hoffentlich auch
vorgehen warum ist denn dieses verfahren
so viel besser als diese ganze
kandidatenkür diese gerade erst vor zehn
monaten absolviert haben frau kramp
karrenbauer ist noch gar nicht lange ab
beim parteivorsitz haben wir aus meiner
sicht ein sehr gutes verfahren gewählt
wir hatten relativ schnell nämlich nach
zwei tagen die drei kandidaten
feststehen haben in den
regionalkonferenzen die mitglieder mit
eingebunden
ich spüre aber schon wenn ich in den
gesprächen bin mit unseren mitgliedern
an der basis dass sie mehr
mitentscheiden wollen dass sich die
zeiten verändert haben beispielsweise zu
2005 als wir angela merkel zur
kanzlerkandidatin gemacht haben dass
heute die mitglieder selbstbewusster
sind und sie wünschen sich einen
motivationsschub dass sie mitmachen
dürfen und wir meinen dass dann der von
ihnen favorisierte friedrich merz bei
einer solchen basis befragung eine art
erdrutsch sieg davontragen bürger ob
friedrich merz zur verfügung steht als
kanzlerkandidat das
wir sehen genauso wie möglicherweise
auch andere kandidaten wir halten
jedenfalls fest die cdu
parteivorsitzende die wird es nicht
automatisch bisher war das ja so wir
haben auch schon erlebt dass
csu-parteivorsitzende angetreten sind
von daher ist das nicht immer ein
automatismus aber sicherlich die
parteivorsitzende hat heute auch noch
mal betont sie will diesen prozess von
vorne führen und darauf setzen wir die
spd ist damit nicht so richtig glücklich
geworden immer wieder in ihrer führung
herum zu kritteln oder immer wieder
neues führungspersonal zu erfinden
drohte cdu da nicht auch darunter zu
leiden
ich persönlich sehe das anders die spd
ist insbesondere deswegen in dem chaos
verhaftet weil sie morgens erklärt dass
sie eigentlich aus der groko aussteigen
will und abends versucht die erfolge der
groko zu verkaufen das funktioniert am
ende nicht man muss gemeinsam hinter
einer sache stehen und dann wird man
auch erfolgreich sein das werden wir als
cdu und csu gemeinsam tun sie bekritteln
ja auch dass nicht die richtigen themen
gesetzt worden seien in den letzten
monaten nun ist dafür nicht nur eine
grid kramp karrenbauer zuständig oder
die kanzlerin angela merkel sondern zum
beispiel auch bei chemie akt der ihr
vorgänger als junge union chef warum
setzt der denn da nicht die richtigen
themen holz i mir ist als
generalsekretär sicherlich in einer
schwierigen rolle weil er eine sehr
große aufgabe vor sich hat gemeinsam mit
der gesamten parteispitze mit annegret
kramp karrenbauer an der spitze
natürlich auch die cdu zu erneuern
nach 14 jahren kanzlerschaft angela
merkel ist das ein riesiges unterfangen
und wir werden ihnen dabei unterstützen
dass es unsere aufgabe auch als junge
union er kommt aus unserer aus unseren
reihen und deswegen hat er auch da
unsere volle unterstützung aber richtige
durchschlagskraft hat er bisher nicht
entwickeln können er hat beispielsweise
beim thema neue digitale kommunikation
neue wege eingeschlagen der wieder im
kopf das wiso video waren das jetzt
nicht so die neuen wege in der
digitalisierung das war sicherlich
anschließend dann auch der neue prozess
den er mit angestoßen hat wo wir als
junge union auch einen zehn-punkte-plan
mit an die hand gegeben haben der
eingeschlossen ist in die neue digital
strategie der bundes-cdu und deswegen
finde ich dass wir da durchaus neue wege
gehen man muss aber auch sagen für die
meisten parteien in deutschland ist
dieser prozess neue digitale
kommunikation etwas wo wir die kanzlerin
hat das mal als neuland
bezeichnet betreten und deswegen muss
auch ein gewisses voran scheitern
möglich sein dass man eben nicht alles
sofort und perfekt machen können sondern
dass ein weg sich auch entwickelt das
stichwort voran scheitern und haben die
wahlen in thüringen ein ziemlich
entsetzliches ergebnis für die cdu
gebracht mike mohring wollte mit ramelow
offen reden auch ergebnisoffen das sorgt
für empörung
andere in der thüringischen cdu würden
gerne mit der afg reden halten sie das
genauso viel ausgeschlossen wir haben
einen bundes parteitagsbeschluss der
klar sagt dass wir keine koalition keine
kooperation mit der linkspartei mit der
alternative für deutschland eingehen
diese positive positionen unterstreiche
ich und die unterstütze ich wir dürfen
dort nicht beliebig werden sondern für
uns muss klar sein mit diesen
extremistischen parteien mit den
populistischen parteien von rechts und
links wird es mit uns keine koalition
keine zusammenarbeit geben sagt tilman
kube der chef der junge und das
interview danke frau slomka
das thüringer wahlergebnis sorgt nicht
nur bei der cdu für schlechte laune
sogar die linke die ihr historisch
bestes wahlergebnis eingefahren hat kann
sich ja nicht ganz ungetrübt freuen
angesichts des schwierigen
mehrheitsverhältnisse
die spd wiederum ist entsetzt die grünen
enttäuscht
und selbst bei der afg sind nicht alle
gleichermaßen begeistert über das
erstarken des rechtsradikalen flügels
denen alexander gauland gewohnt
schmerzfrei jetzt als die mitte der
partei bezeichnet christiane hübscher
berichtet
björn höcker wirft der hauptstadtpresse
gerne vor dass sie einseitig berichtet
sogar manipuliere gegen die art die er
tut das auch heute wieder
aber das blitzlicht in berlin genießt er
dennoch seine thüringer fdp hat ihr
ergebnis verdoppelt die meisten jungen
wähler und die meisten nichtwähler
mobilisiert wir sind die junge vitale
volkspartei des ostens und davon bin ich
überzeugt dass wir gemeinsam in den
nächsten jahren diese afg zu einer
jungen vitalen volkspartei
gesamtdeutschlands entwickelt werden
regieren wenn niemand mit höcker ob er
für seinen wahlerfolg nun zumindest
einen posten im neuen ard bundesvorstand
fordert das ließ ja heute offen
parteichef gauland jedenfalls bleibt
dabei rechtsaußen höcke als flügel
gründer vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
gehöre zur mitte der partei wenn jemand
spitzenkandidat von thüringen knapp 25
prozent der wähler hinter sich vereinigt
dann ist er bestimmt keine randfigur
ratlosigkeit bei der bundes-spd
einstellig nun schon zum zweiten mal
wieder untergegangen in der
polarisierung zwischen amtsinhaber und
afd
und noch immer kein rezept dagegen nur
entsetzen
wir kämpfen dagegen auch in zukunft das
die afg mit diesem ergebnis im höcke
land ein faschist an der spitze der
liste mit diesem ergebnis nach hause
ging gestern ist für mich und für uns
als spd zutiefst bedrückend die fdp
zieht nach zehn jahren erstmals wieder
in einen ostdeutschen landtag ein wohl
nur fünf stimmen waren es am ende die
sie über die fünf prozent linie brachten
jede stimme zählt nie war dieser satz
weise als heute trotzdem selbst einen
tolerieren einer minderheitsregierung
ramelow komme nicht in frage gibt fdp
chef lindner vor an ministerpräsident
der in der ddr kein unrechtsstaat sieht
dass ein solcher einem historischen
fehlurteil unterliegt auch ganz
persönlich und danach soll thomas
kemmerich er den zum ministerpräsidenten
wählen
die unglaubwürdig wird man gegenüber der
eigenen wählerschaft
die grünen machen pause vom höhenflug
ein minus von 0,5 prozent der thüringer
wahlkampf sei noch härter gewesen als in
sachsen und brandenburg räumt robert
habeck 1
trotzdem dürfe sich jetzt niemand
wegducken lindners ausschließeritis
sorgt bei ihnen für ein jamaika déjà vu
wir sind hier nicht mehr in wünsch dir
was sondern es geht darum dass wir unter
völlig veränderten parteipolitischen
demokratischen bedingungen demokratische
mehrheiten herstellen
deswegen von unserer seite noch mal der
dringende appell an alle die ernste die
ernsthaftigkeit der lage zu verstehen
und entsprechend zumindest einen
gesprächskanal aufzuhalten lager grenzen
überwinden politische experimente wagen
die erfurter verhältnisse fordern auch
berlin heraus ob die thüringer fdp
wähler ihr kreuz trotz oder wegen
gemachten fest steht sie haben sich
jedenfalls nicht an ihm gestört auch
nicht daran dass der radikale
parteiflügel den er repräsentiert im
visier des verfassungsschutzes steht in
seinem eigenen wahlkreis konnte sich
allerdings nicht durchsetzen sondern
unterlag deutlich dem kandidaten der cdu
was allerdings auch kein trost ist für
diejenigen thüringer die das
wahlergebnis schockiert und die sich
sorgen machen um wachsenden rassismus
und antisemitismus im land andreas
postel mit einem stimmungsbild aus
thüringen am tag nach der wahl stehen
dem landesrabbiner von thüringen
sorgenfalten ins gesicht geschrieben
seine gemeinde ist tief verunsichert
durch das hohe abschneiden der afd
das wahlergebnis ist besorgniserregend
und gerade eben hier in thüringen wo es
einen vorsitzenden der afg gibt der laut
gerichtsurteil als faschist bezeichnet
werden darf ist es doch etwas wo wir uns
als landesgemeinde so große sorgen
machen es ist etwas ins rutschen geraten
im land der dichter und denker im land
von weimar und buchenwald das
wahlergebnis macht sichtbarer was
soziologen seit jahren messen wir haben
vor der wahl eine befragung gemacht bei
der 71 prozent der afg wählerinnen aus
thüringen angegeben haben
dass die afg in thüringen nicht zurecht
sondern genau richtig sei und das
spricht dafür dass es eben nicht nur um
einen diffusen protest geht sondern auch
dafür dass hier eine übereinstimmung mit
der rechtsradikalen programmatik der
thüringer fdp vorhanden ist da braucht
es zeit zum innehalten
doch das lässt die dramaturgie des
politischen betriebs kaum zu die
schwierigen verhältnisse im kleinen
thüringen werden zum großen thema in
berlin ministerpräsident bodo ramelow
und seine linke erstmals stärkste kraft
in einem bundesland mit dem anspruch zum
regieren jetzt haben wir die situation
dass es keine automatische koalition
gibt es gibt keine automatische
farbenlehre
aber es gibt demokraten die in diesem
land stark verankert sind
minderheitsregierung tolerieren die
schwäche seiner partner spd und grüne
zwingt zu ungewöhnlichen demokratischen
experimenten die stärke der afg macht
die regierungsbildung zum kraftakt die
stärke der afg hat aber auch ihre
grenzen im katholischen eichsfeld liegt
der wahlkreis von björn höcke
ausgerechnet im konservativen stammland
der cdu wollte er hier das direktmandat
erobert
doch damit ist er gescheitert tadeusz
könig ein junger cdu mann aus
heiligenstadt heute mit abstand die
meisten stimmen
herkert groß angekündigt hier das
eichsfeld sturmreif zu schießen sich das
direktmandat zu holen und was dabei
rausgekommen ist hat der wahlabend
gezeigt wahlamt hat gezeigt dass er
keine chance hat immerhin das ein signal
an diesem tag für die cdu in thüringen
ansonsten suchen sie einen weg aus dem
jammertal am abend tagt cdu präsidium
und landesvorstand mike mohring will
zumindest reden mit bodo ramelow
bodo ramelow wollte mit rot rot grüne
mehrheit hat er nicht bekommen wir
wollten mit der starken mit in der
mehrheit die haben auch nicht bekommen
ist es ganz selbstverständlich dass man
interesse des landes miteinander reden
in sorge um sein politisches erbe hat
sich selbst der hochbetagte bernhard
vogel auf den weg nach erfurt gemacht
das wort liegt jetzt nicht in erster
linie bei uns dass auch wir
gegebenenfalls wenn herr ramelow das
wünscht gesprächsbereit sein müssen
will ich ausdrücklich hinzufügen bodo
ramelow will sich schnell im parlament
zur wahl stellen sagt er
bis dahin führt er die geschäfte weiter
in der thüringer staatskanzlei soweit
erst mal unsere berichterstattung am tag
nach der tür
viele videos und infos dazu gibt es auch
auf heute.de und dort finden sie auch
das vorläufige amtliche ergebnis auf das
er vor allem die fdp gebannt gewartet
habt und jetzt geht es erstmal andere
nachrichten des tages
der jüdische weltkongress hat ein verbot
von parteien gefordert die so wörtlich
die neo nazi ideologie unterstützen
das sagte der präsident leider bei der
verleihung des theodor herzl preises an
kanzlerin merkel in münchen
mehrere redner lobten merkels engagement
für das jüdische leben in deutschland
merkel selbst sagte jüdische kultur und
geschichte seien teil der identität
deutschlands und müssten geschützt
werden
jüngste entwicklungen wie der anschlag
von halle müssten alle mit sorge
erfüllen
im südwesten frankreichs sind bei einem
angriff auf eine moschee zwei menschen
schwer verletzt worden
ein 84 jähriger franzose mit
rechtsradikaler gesinnung eröffnete das
feuer vor der moschee
die polizei nahm den mutmaßlichen
schützen kurze zeit später an seinem
wohnhaus fest man werde hass in
frankreich niemals tolerieren erklärte
präsident makro der exit darf erneut
verschoben werden wie von london
beantragt hat die eu eine verlängerung
über den 31 oktober hinaus zugestimmt
demnach läuft die frist für den austritt
großbritanniens bis 31 januar
dem parlament in london ist
premierminister johnson am abend mit
seinem antrag auf neuwahlen am 12
dezember gescheitert er bekam nicht die
erforderliche zweidrittel wert nun soll
es möglicherweise schon morgen einen
neuen vorstoß für vorgezogene neuwahlen
geben
mit einer gesetzes variante weil der
eine einfache mehrheit genügt noch bis
morgen nachmittag läuft die frist bis zu
der die kurdischen kämpfer aus dem
nordosten syriens im grenzgebiet zur
türkei abziehen sollen
der türkische außenminister davutoglu
hat heute gedroht dass diejenigen die
bis dahin das gebiet nicht verlassen
haben vom türkischen militär angegriffen
würden
den rückzug der kurden hatten russland
und die türkei in der vergangenen woche
ausgehandelt
der missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung röhrig plädiert für die
einführung eines pflichtfachs
medienkompetenz an schulen
hintergrund sind die bundesweiten
durchsuchungen und ermittlungen gegen 21
verdächtige im alter zwischen 14 und 26
jahren die kinderpornografisches
material über soziale netzwerke weiter
verbreitet haben sollen
das bundeskriminalamt warnte angesichts
des falles dass kinder und jugendliche
mitunter leichtfertig
kinderpornografische dateien
verbreiteten
es handelt es sich hier aber nicht um
bagatelldelikte und die polizei gehe
solchen fällen konsequent nach in
argentinien gibt es einen machtwechsel
bei der präsidentschaftswahl hat der
konservative amtsinhaber marke deutlich
gegen den mitte links kandidatin
fernandez verloren
berlin ist fernandes und seine
stellvertreterin die umstrittene ex
präsidentin cristina kirchner setzten im
wahlkampf auf soziale themen argentinien
die zweitgrößte wirtschaft amerikas
rutschte unter markus vierjähriger
präsidentschaft in eine schwere krise
das land leidet unter staatsschulden und
einer galoppierenden inflation und ein
drittel der bevölkerung lebt in armut
nicht nur seine dicke berta wird in
erinnerung bleiben mario draghi hatte
während der europäischen schuldenkrise
seine geldpolitik mit dieser riesigen
kanone verglichen die im ersten
weltkrieg zum einsatz kam und dass er
ausgerechnet ein deutsches geschützt
nannte war allerdings auch ein bisschen
schräg wenn man bedenkt dass seine
politik des leichten geldes vor allem in
deutschland auf kritik stößt
wohl noch nie zuvor hat ein präsident
der europäischen zentralbank so
polarisiert wie der italiener traf
seine amtszeit ist nun zu ende heute
wurde er feierlich verabschiedet dunkles
meister hat das beobachtet
in acht jahren habe er sie nie gebraucht
scherzte mario draghi bei der übergabe
der sitzungs blogger an christine
lagarde europas spitze zeigt den
scheidenden ezb-präsidenten anerkennung
frankreichs präsident makro
bundeskanzlerin merkel
italiens staatspräsident materieller
europas politiker betonen draghis rolle
bei der euro krise den euro durch
unruhige see navigiert kontroversen bist
du nicht aus dem weg gegangen und wir
können heute auf eine erfolgreiche
währung blicken mit der rettung des euro
haben sie den schutz europas und seiner
völker gewahrt und gestärkt mario draghi
hat die geldpolitik der ezb geprägt
angetreten mitten in der euro-krise im
november 2011 war er schnell gefordert
griechenland stand vor der staatspleite
während europas politiker stritten
handelte draghi rettete so den euro
die cvp wir haben eine niedrige
inflationsrate wir haben ein stabiles
geld der euro hat die krise überstanden
und daran hat er sicherlich sein anteil
gehabt
insbesondere der kauf von staatsanleihen
im wert von fast drei billionen euro
bleibt umstritten
mit nullzins und strafzins für banken
wurde draghi zum schrecken der sparer
so mussten die deutschen haushalte in
seiner amtszeit geschätzt 625 milliarden
euro an zins einbußen verkraften
gleichzeitig aber sparten die deutschen
durch billige kredite 281 milliarden an
zinsen
unterm strich steht ein verlust von 344
milliarden euro die auswirkungen auf das
finanzsystem insgesamt auf
lebensversicherungen auf das alter
sparen auf pensionskassen auf das
finanzsystem insgesamt sind inzwischen
so stark dass sie mögliche positive
effekte inzwischen deutlich überwiegen
mario draghi polarisiert in frankfurt
dabei ist damit sich und seinen
entscheidungen im reinen
was denn ihr zb rad immer geeint hat und
die nummer einen wird mehr als es in
teilen wird es gibt verpflichtung das
engagement und die leidenschaft für euro
mit christine lagarde bekommt die ezb
eine erfahrene krisenmanagerin
sie sieht den draghi an vorbild ihr erbe
ist für uns die herausforderung
bestleistung zu erbringen erwartungen
mehr als zu erfüllen das mandat
umzusetzen und der europäischen sache zu
dienen
tragisch bilanz ist nicht unumstritten
sein vermächtnis aber bleibt den euro
vor dem zusammenbruch bewahrt zu haben
tja und mit dem thema gibt es jetzt auch
in der börse erst nochmal weiterhin der
trage geht lagarde kommt auch die neue
ezb-chef hin gilt als befürworterin
einer lockeren geldpolitik frank
bethmann magath oder was ich hier
trotzdem auch eigene akzente setzen was
wird da erwartet na ja genau darauf darf
man in den nächsten wochen und monaten
gespannt sein eines ist klar die
ultralockere geldpolitik wird sie
erstmal fortführen das klang ja eben in
ihrem statement das erbe tragisches
weiterführen zu wollen schon an
aber dennoch wird sie etwas ändern
müssen künftig will sie die
entscheidungen der notenbank besser
erklären wie sie beim heutigen festakt
andeutet an mario draghi gerichtet sagt
sie der euro gehört nicht dir wie du
weißt er gehört auch nicht der ezb der
euro gehört den bürgern europas und
wir stehen an ihrer seite die politik
der notenbank den bürgern verständlicher
zu erklären ist das gebot der stunde
nicht die ezb eine andere bedeutende
notenbank hat dies längst schwarz auf
weiß die bank of england fand heraus
eine rede von donald trump verstehen 70
prozent der menschen einen song von der
elvis presley immerhin 60 prozent doch
einen zeitungsartikel über die
geldpolitik also über das was notenbank
machen nur 20 prozent der leute klartext
ist also gefragt um verständnis aber
auch vertrauen zurückzugewinnen 43
prozent der euro bürger haben derzeit
kein vertrauen in die ezb wie eine
jüngste umfrage des europäischen
parlaments bestätigt christine lagarde
wird also auch daran gemessen werden ob
sie ihre entscheidungen besser verkaufen
kann als ihr vorgänger frank bethmann
vielen dank gerne bei den gesetzlichen
krankenkassen steigt der
durchschnittliche satz für den
zusatzbeitrag im kommenden jahr um 0,2
prozentpunkte auf 11 prozent dass das
bundesgesundheitsministerium mitgeteilt
allerdings legt jede krankenkasse selbst
fest wie hoch ihr tatsächlicher
zusatzbeitrag ausfällt grund für die
erhöhung im durchschnitt die ausgaben
steigen stärker als die einnahmen
bei einem digital gipfel der
bundesregierung diskutieren heute und
morgen mehrere hundert vertreter aus
politik wirtschaft wissenschaft und
gesellschaft über den digitalen wandel
schwerpunkt der konferenz sind dortmund
ist das thema digitale plattformen
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier war
angesichts der weltweiten konkurrenz für
ein europäisches engagement
morgen will er pläne für eine
europäische cloud lösung vorstellen in
teilen kaliforniens wüten weiter schwere
waldbrände
der gouverneur hat den notstand
ausgerufen am morgen brach auch im
nordwesten von los angeles ein feuer aus
bei einer wichtigen vielbefahrenen
autobahn
am größten ist nach angaben der behörden
derzeit ein feuer etwa 120 kilometer
nördlich von san francisco
insgesamt waren rund 185000 menschen
aufgerufen ihre häuser zu verlassen
mehrere tausend feuerwehrleute sowie
löschflugzeuge und hubschrauber sind
gegen die flammen im einsatz
das war's und heute journal mit dem zdf
montagskino geht es gleich weiter
und danach um 0 uhr meldet sich da eine
brücke hofft mit heute plus es morgen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
gunnar liebe zuschauer mit sonne nebel
und etwas regen geht es auch morgen
wieder weiter also ganz ähnliches wetter
wie heute die temperaturen dabei um die
zehn grad kalt ist es bereits in
skandinavien winterliche kälte mit
schneefällen und dann haben wir diese
grenze der temperatur war frankreich
über den alten ungarn wenn südlich davon
haben wir richtige wärme noch mit 20 bis
25 grad und diese grenze wird gebildet
durch massive wolken die immer wieder
regen bringen und diese wollten bekommen
nachschub aus westen auch in den
nächsten 24 stunden noch dann morgen
tagsüber wird die wolken grenze ein
bisschen weiter nach süden gedrückt aber
den regen an den alpen haben wir immer
noch heute nacht vor allen dingen in der
zweiten nachthälfte wieder etwas stärker
sonst bilden sich verbreitet nebelfelder
und an den küsten kann es hier und da
noch regenschauer geben
es wird auch mal frostig vor einigen
norddeutschland lüneburger heide morgen
schulen minus 1 grad tagsüber wechseln
deinen norddeutschland sonne und wolken
da wird es ganz freundlich nach osten
hin muss man ab und zu mit kleineren
regenschauern rechnen bei diesem mäßige
nordostwind auch in der mitte sieht
eigentlich ganz freundlich aus sonnig
aber nach süden hin haben wir wollten
die ziehen über den süden nach osten und
an den alpen bringen sie halt immer noch
regen der langsam nachlässt in die
wolken grenze zieht sich so langsam zu
den alpen zurück tagsüber die
temperaturen sind eher noch etwas
niedriger als heute
6 bis 10 grad meist hier am niederrhein
können auch 12 grad erreicht werden und
die aussichten es geht mit sonne und
nebel erst einmal weiter freitag ändert
sich das ganze dann kommt von westen
kräftiger regen auf und es wird langsam
etwas milder ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie es gut